perfecto estamos en la recta final de la
primera sección de problemas y creo que
podríamos llamarlo la primera sección
experimental de vídeos sobre ese tema y
bueno espero que con suerte esté
trabajando de manera decente y te gusten
los vídeos así que vamos ser el problema
17 el problema 17 y que me diste este
problema 17 me dicen tengo la ecuación
2 veces x 1 esto es igual a ese y lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale x + 1
yo lo que quiero saber es a cuánto
equivale x 1 y bueno lo primero que
vamos a hacer es empezar con esta
ecuación yo sé que a más 2 veces x + 1
esto es igual a ese y si lo que
necesitamos es saber el valor de x + 1
lo que voy a hacer es despejar a x + 1 y
para despejar a x + 1 lo primero que voy
a hacer es restar a de ambos lados de la
ecuación voy a restar a de este lado y
voy a restar a de este otro lado de tal
manera que am y ya se cancelen y
solamente me quede que 2 que multiplica
a x + 1 esto sea igual a ese menos a a
ese menos an y ahora sí para obtener el
valor de x + 1 lo que voy a hacer es
dividir todo entre 2 voy a dividir esta
parte entre 2 y voy a dividir esta otra
parte también entre 2 de tal manera que
este 2 y este 2 se van a ir
y ya me va a quedar que x + 1 esto va a
ser igual a s menos a todo esto entre 2
y ya está ya tengo el valor de x + 1
expresado en términos de ese idea y guau
lo sorprendente es encontrarnos un
problema que nos quite tan poco tiempo a
estas alturas de la prueba porque casi
siempre los problemas se ponen cada vez
más difíciles pero pues aquí están creo
que la razón de este problema es que
normalmente uno intentaría resolver para
x para después averiguar cuánto vale x +
1 pero el truco es no romper la
expresión x 1 lo puedes ver como si
fuera una nueva variable esto lo hemos
visto en alguno de mis vídeos pero el
chiste es no distribuir este 2
multiplicando tanto x como a 1 si lo que
quieres es resolver esto para x + 1 así
de fácil
llegas a la solución y por cierto este
es el inciso b de la respuesta de este
problema así que mi respuesta es l
y el siguiente problema estoy volteando
la hoja así que podemos pensar que
estamos llegando a la parte en donde
están los verdaderos problemas difíciles
de esta prueba el siguiente problema
tiene una gráfica así que no creo que me
quepa aquí y por lo tanto déjame borrar
este pizarrón para empezar uno nuevo el
siguiente problema que es muy problema
18 tiene una gráfica así que déjame
hacerte esta gráfica que tiene este
problema para esto necesito dos ejes voy
a decir que este es uno de mis ejes este
otro va a ser mi otro eje y bueno voy a
decir que este es mi eje de leyes este
es mi eje x y tengo una gráfica de una
función la función se ve más o menos así
y aquí tengo unos valores para x tengo
una escala
2 aquí tengo el valor de 3 y por acá
tengo el valor de 4 y además tengo una
línea límite que me va a servir de
frontera es mi línea x igual a 4 y bueno
todo esto porque aquí tengo una región
encerrada la cual voy a poner de color
gris esta es mi región importante por
cierto me dicen que esta función se
llama y es igual a efe de x y además me
dice que me fije en todos los puntos que
estén adentro de esta región que va a
tener como coordenadas a b y entonces ya
que me dieron esta gráfica lo que me
preguntan es lo siguiente de estas
afirmaciones que voy a poner a
continuación cuáles de ellas son
verdaderas y me ponen tres afirmaciones
la primera afirmación me dice a siempre
tiene que ser menor o igual que 4 me
preguntan si esta es verdadera o es
falsa la segunda afirmación me dice que
siempre es
o igual que en todos los puntos que
están en esta región me preguntan si b
es menor o igual que a y la tercera de
estas afirmaciones me dice que ven
siempre es menor o igual que f de a
vamos a ver si estas afirmaciones son
ciertas cuáles de estas afirmaciones son
ciertas bueno así que vamos a intentar
ver si la primera afirmación es cierta
dice a tiene que ser menor o igual a 4
es decir que cualquier punto que tenga
en esta región su valor en a va a ser
menor o igual que 4 así que imagínate
que tengo yo a este punto esto que estoy
dibujando aquí va a ser su valor en vez
mientras que por otra parte es de que
estoy dibujando aquí va a ser su valor
en a para cualquiera de estos puntos que
estén adentro de esta región y fíjate
que su valor en am puede variar desde 0
hasta 4 no puede ser más grande que 4
porque se saldría esta región y no puede
ser más chico que 0 porque se saldría de
esta región
entonces am tiene que estar entre 0 y 4
que justo es lo que me dice mi primera
afirmación tiene que ser menor que 4 y
por tanto esta afirmación es cierta
ahora vamos a ver si se cumple la
segunda b sea menor o igual que a
siempre en esta región y no sé algo me
huele a que esto no se cumple como
podríamos llegar a esa conclusión y creo
que esta afirmación no es cierta pero
como podríamos decir que esta afirmación
no es cierta ya se se encuentra un punto
aquí se encuentra un punto aquí en esta
región tal que su valor en vez sea más
grande que su valor en a qué punto me
podría tomar
creo que este punto por aquí no puede
funcionar fíjate en ese punto de ahí su
coordenada en b va a ser más grande que
su coordenada en am si yo me fijo en su
valor en b en su valor en b es más
grande que su valor en am es decir la
distancia que hay de aquí acá
grande que la distancia que hay de que
acá y eso se nota por lo tanto esto me
está dando pie a decir que esta
afirmación no es cierta ya encontré un
ave para la cual no se cumple esto en
esta región así que vamos a fijarnos en
nuestra tercera afirmación mi tercera
afirmación me dice que sea menor o igual
que fedea así que imagínate que yo tengo
este punto de aquí si este es el punto a
como ven dónde está esta idea pues efe
de a es el valor que toma a en esta
función es decir va a ser este punto de
kim este punto de aquí tiene como
coordenada en efe es decir que la
distancia que yo tengo aquí ésta es cda
y si te das cuenta aquí efe es mucho más
grande que vean eso se va a cumplir para
cualquier punto en esta región puede
saber vamos a tomar nosotros por ejemplo
este de aquí si estoy aquí es am
entonces este de aquí sería b y entonces
este que está aquí arriba sería efe de
am sería mi valor en rojo sangre d
y otra vez efe queda arriba debe y
porque es esto cierto porque si te das
cuenta que está definido adentro de esta
región y esta región está delimitada por
fx no tengo en ningún punto arriba de
esta gráfica justo así es cómo construir
esta región por lo tanto esta afirmación
siempre es cierta y entonces ya tengo
mis dos afirmaciones que son ciertas el
1 y el 3 las cuales son las respuestas
que están en el inciso d al inciso dvd 2
esa es mi respuesta ya no me da tiempo
de hacer otro problema así que vamos a
dejarlo aquí y mejor hago los dos
últimos problemas de esta sección en el
siguiente vídeo así que nos vemos en el
siguiente